this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
[Music]
hey wisecrack greg here to talk about
our favorite sociopath
rick sanchez if you spent five minutes
reading weird reddit threads or watching
rick and morty you know our dude is the
smartest jerk in the whole wide universe
and yet there's one thing he's uniquely
incompetent at
forming close relationships he
sacrificed himself to save all of us
rick
he died well at least he didn't die in
vain he got these crystals
and these babies just saved this lame
ass party up and dumped up
he can't tell his daughter apart from
the clone he made of her and his former
best friend bird person
now exists only as a mangled screaming
corpse
in rick's garage all right we'll give
you a little more time in a universe in
which he sometimes seems all powerful
rick is almost completely alone so what
can rick's loneliness teach us about
friendship
is he simply too brilliant and special a
genius alpha loner
that pathetic normies could never
possibly understand
whatever yeah whatever a dad makes a
toilet look like r2d2 when it breaks the
front page of reddit but i'm charles
manson because i gave you your own world
instead of an ipad
could his loneliness possibly be good
for him or is he just a sad
old cosmic sex pervert and what does
this all have to do with rick's desire
to make
sweet sweet love to a whole last planet
i i don't understand isn't it obvious
morty
i [ __ ] the planet let's find out with
the help of one of the dudes who
basically invented philosophy
in this wisecrack edition on rick and
morty why does rick
a planet spoilers ahead for rick and
morty and before we continue i want to
give a shout out to this week's sponsor
surfsharkvpn with privacy becoming a
bigger concern for online consumers
every day
there's never been a better time to get
a vpn surfsharkvpn
secures your data with industry-leading
measures by using uncrackable encryption
and the most secure vpn protocols and
aside from providing privacy to your
browsing sessions
a vpn could be helpful for a handful of
reasons
say you're planning to travel and need
to find a flight hotel or car rental
when you search unprotected vendors use
your location to discriminate and give
you prices
assuming that you don't have other
options or are unfamiliar with the area
with the vpn you can have peace of mind
that you found the best deal
surfsharkvpn is fast and easy to install
and jam packed with extra features so
you're really getting a bang for your
buck
most vpns charge extra to connect to
multiple devices
but with surf shark vpn you can connect
to an unlimited amount
with one subscription that means that
your phone
laptop smart tv and even your console
will be protected by the industry
leading encryption check out
surfsharkvpn today
by going to surfshark dot deal slash
wisecrack
and use a promo code wisecrack for 83
percent off
and an extra three months for free now
back to the show at first glance it
might seem as if rick does possess at
least some meaningful connections
obviously his relationship with morty is
central to the show
and i'm i'm so proud of you i only wish
you could have bought more i
i love buying things so much morty rick
are you
do you need to go to the hospital i love
you morty rick insists on taking him on
almost all of his adventures and despite
his sometimes sadistic way of showing it
he seems to genuinely care about him and
gets a little bitter when others occupy
morty's attention
everybody [ __ ] off but the relationship
that exists between rick and morty
isn't really friendship to see why we
can turn to one of the founding fathers
of just about
any subject you studied in school
aristotle the concept of friendship is
super important aristotle's discussion
of ethics as he sees it friendship is a
necessary aspect of living well
and becoming a moral person that's
because our friends
help us know and do what is right
helping us to become
as aristotle will put it virtuous and
wise
also friends are just a nice and good
thing to have
without friends aristotle tells us no
one would choose to live
even if he possessed all other goods the
philosopher distinguishes between
three sorts of friendships friendships
based on utility
where the friend is loved because they
are useful friendships based on pleasure
whether friend is loved because they are
witty or attractive or fun
and finally complete friendships where
the friend is loved simply for being who
they are
without offering any specific use or
benefit and we can see
all three versions of friendships at
play across the wider rick and morty
universe
rick's relationship with morty is a
classic example of a friendship based on
utility
he likes morty to go on adventures with
him because morty's idiot brainwaves
cancel out his genius ones making it
harder for his enemies to detect him
when a rick is with a morty the genius
waves get canceled out by the uh
morty waves meanwhile the relationship
rick develops with tony the shy pooper
might be a friendship based on pleasure
if you touch my toilet again you die i
need a friend
i have a million cooler friends than you
i'll be seeing you you'll be dying we're
gonna be friends gonna be dead
even though he won't admit it rick is
sad after tony dies because it means
he can't have fun trying to humiliate
him for using a secret toilet anymore
congrats tony have fun with your stupid
toilet that you get to use all by
yourself now
and who can blame them man most of my
healthiest adult friendships were
birthed
from striking up a conversation with a
stranger making a number two combo meal
in a chick-fil-a bathroom but according
to aristotle there is a problem with
those first two types of friendships
they're not gonna last because the
friend is only valued for what they're
able to do for us
our relationship with them is easily
dissolved once they stop being useful
are enjoyable there is no real evidence
that rick especially values
his morty as opposed to any other
possible morty whose brain waves could
be used for the same purpose
how many ricks have you had five i see
in contrast
the third type of friendship a complete
friendship is able to last because a
friend is loved for who they are
themselves
in a complete friendship both people
want the other to have and achieve good
things
it's less a transaction between two
parties and more a mutual two-person fan
club
and in case you're interested i'm
currently accepting applications for my
own fan club so uh
hop on in the comments if you're a good
candidate aristotle specifies that
complete friendship
is rare since it can only truly arise
between those who are
good and alike and virtue but certainly
the other members of the smith sanchez
family
seem to possess something much closer to
it jerry and beth aren't particularly
useful to one another
and beth appears to get very little
pleasure out of being with her husband
we will have as much fun as possible on
our
titanic themed getaway let's lose the
tude please it's supposed to be romantic
but despite this they remain drawn
together out of love
i was impressed dad he saved my life no
thanks to you
likewise morty and summer for all they
get on each other's nerves
share a close sibling bond rick on the
other hand has become more and more
isolated from others as the series
progresses
hi i've placed an auto-response chip in
my brain so i can spend time with my
family
but you are spending time with your
family thank you for talking to rick
all right i'm finished with my breakfast
and my amazon wishlist there's
admittedly at least one example of a
complete friendship involving rick
which has been depicted on the show in
the season two episode total recall
he is seen sharing a deep bond with a
talking pencil
named pennsylvester
of course pennsylvester was actually a
member of the species
of parasitic space worms who took the
smith sanchez family over
by inserting themselves into their
memories not exactly the kind of stunt
you should pull on your buddy right
so why is rick so isolated again
aristotle can help us out
he thinks friendships need to involve
equality if great differences arise
between two friends
in terms of how good they are as people
or how much money or power they have
not only will they struggle to remain
close but one will feel inferior
the others superior as he put it for
those who are much inferior
to kings do not deem themselves worthy
to be friends with them
this is why lebron james goes on
vacation with dwayne wade and chris paul
and not a 23 year old car salesman in
training
who just learned you actually have to do
your taxes
rick is clearly not the best person in
the universe
far from it he makes kenny powers look
like a decent guy
if anybody wants to pick on anybody in
class aim for him because
i ain't watching but he is the most
intelligent
and this has given him powers that far
transcend those
of the average human this is most
obvious in the case of his relationship
with jerry
who rick has nothing but contempt for
because of his average
intelligence one possible rick has
opened an interdimensional daycare for
ricks to leave their jerry's in
if they ever accidentally tag along on
their adventures
i don't know how this works help me what
the
aristotle thinks that friendship is
especially impossible
between human beings and gods since gods
are better than humans
to the greatest degree and you know are
immortal
and have the power to give and take life
and whatnot
so if it seems impossible for lebron and
bryce the young car salesman to be best
friends
imagine how hard it would be for an
average dude to be friends with zeus
or any other resident of mount olympus
true friendship is between
equals who desire the absolute best for
one another
and zeus is never going to be able to
wish that some dude named brandon
was his equal mount olympus is full
brandon
go home no one wants you here go make a
human friend
so if aristotle a real friendship
grounded in equal goodness
needs to be between two human beings he
probably didn't intend to get to the
heart of rick's problems with forming
relationships
he was reportedly more of a bob's
burgers guy
but he did rick's powers have detached
him from his humanity
to the extent that he sometimes forgets
the word for humans
summer's just a hyper-emotional needy
little it's the word i'm looking for
here
a human over the course of the series
rick has become increasingly more and
more powerful
and increasingly more given to
describing himself as a sword of god
if god exists it's [ __ ] me the only
entity seems to feel anything like the
same affinity with is bugs bunny
to me this was all just a bit like when
bugs bunny with the opera singer for 20
minutes and this makes sense
rick has god-like powers over his
environment he's able to manipulate the
fabric of not only his own universe
but of an infinity of possible realities
his tiniest whims can alter
intergalactic history
also rick might be unable to die and all
that explains rick's peculiar desire to
do
body on body stuff with planets or
collective minds
because in banging a god-like entity he
might feel equal to one
for instance unity rick's on-again
off-again hive-mind girlfriend
explicitly states that her goal is one
day to absorb
every conscious mind in the universe and
become what the single-minded once
called a god
oh i like that oh that's pretty sexy he
relates to unity
because this is something he can also
aspire to
in a way that both his human family and
the vast majority of his alien
acquaintances
simply cannot but no matter how many
lives he creates or how many hive minds
he goes all the way with
rick is not actually a god he might have
certain godlike powers but his appetites
and interests
remained all too flawed and all too
human this is good in a way
rick probably could rule the universe if
he wanted to but he's more
liable to get distracted by playing roy
at blips and chits
holy [ __ ] this guy's taking roy off the
grid this guy doesn't have a social
security number for roy
but it also makes it harder for him to
relate productively
to the other entities that might
otherwise be his peers
case in point his relationship with
unity who upon hooking up with rick
is quickly derailed in her divine
ambitions as she strives instead to
satisfy his
every horny whim their relationship has
the potential to be a complete
friendship
but thanks to rick it never becomes
anything more than a friendship of
pleasure or as the kids call it
buddies unity could you get rick out
here please he's
unavailable he's having sex with you we
get it gross
aristata also tells us that human beings
are between
beasts and gods with elements of the
animal and the divine
we're able to speak and exercise reason
but we also lie
cheat burp and fall asleep during our
mom's birthday zone
and this rick is no exception he's just
edged slightly closer than most of us
to the god side because of his science
fuel powers
some ricks have attempted to overcome
their loneliness by banding together
along with their mortys as the citadel
of ricks
but even leaving aside the citadel of
rick's well-documented political
problems
the rig that the show focuses on rick
c137
refuses to join the citadel because he
hates other rigs and why does rick c137
hate other ricks maybe i hate myself
maybe i think i deserve to die i i don't
i
don't know in fact unity aside rick
hates pretty much
every single other entity he encounters
who is it all like him
to the point of physical violence from
zeus the literal god
and the actual father of his planet
lover's children
to zeb zamflork the smartest man in the
mini universe
recreated to power his car for aristotle
this would also be significant since as
he insists
you can only be a good friend to others
if you are able to love yourself as well
aristotle calls the friend another self
we recognize ourselves
and what is good in our own lives and
our friends
this is why aristotle thinks even if you
had everything else you wanted
you will still need to have your friends
around you to be happy
interestingly perhaps the most obvious
example of such a friendship being
depicted on the show
is in fact between jerry and doofus rick
i.e the dumbest iteration of rick from
an alternate timeline in which everyone
apparently eats their own
i'm not doofus rick i'm rick j 19 zeta
7.
oh is that the timeline where everybody
eats poop jerry you know this guy eats
poop right
hey i don't eat poop you guys are always
so mean to me
he and jerry are kendra's spirits and
doofus rick
is genuinely impressed by his son-in-law
wow you really
are wise jerry i i guess that's why you
work in advertising what's more doofus
rick helps jerry come to terms
with the objective worthlessness of his
prized star wars novelty coin collection
telling him that the joy the coins bring
him matters more than their market value
you bought them because you like them
they have value to you that's what
matters
although their friendship is brief it is
clear that jerry believes doofus rick
somehow completes him that he is the
father-in-law he always wanted
and that the feeling is more than mutual
doof is rick not self-aware enough for
self-loathing
is a better friend to jerry than smart
rick could ever be
but rick c137 is perpetually alienated
from his family because
unlike them he can plausibly aspire to
become a god
he may have manifested some sort of butt
he can do that he is the smartest man in
the universe
however there are plenty of other
entities he has encountered with
who are in a similar situation who might
make a decent friend
but ultimately he remains alone because
he is unable to exist
happily with himself this is why he
pursues seedy affairs with hive minds
and makes unprotected love with planets
he is trying desperately
to compensate for the void he feels
within but his own emotional limitations
prevent these relationships
from being complete friendships and for
all his smarts
he's almost certainly never going to be
wise enough to obtain a community
at the same time he's almost definitely
never going to become a god
but what do you think wisecrack should
rick tone down his erratic genius for
the sake of having some buddies to watch
interdimensional cable with or is the
loneliness worth it
when you can do almost whatever you want
with no consequences
let us know what you think in the
comments thanks as always to our patrons
for your support
hit that subscribe button like you're
making a clone of yourself
to become best friends with and don't
forget to ring that bell
and as always thanks for watching peace
[Music]
you